[Musique]
c'est une rue bien calme la rue de
l'Amiral la case à Saint-Denis une rue
chargée d'histoire où l'on retrouve de
nombreux bâtiments de la Compagnie des
Indes ici ils sont particulièrement bien
conservés mais la mémoire de l'amiral la
case l'est-elle
aussi est-ce que vous savez qui était
l'amiral la case non mais me souvient
puis moi apris tout ça me souvient plus
un personnage célèbre ça me fait penser
à un pirate la case tu B quelque chose
mant qu'est-ce qu'il a bien pu faire cet
homme a signé un traité avec l'Allemagne
à un moment donné la case l'oncle Tom
mais ça CIT dans l'ARM maisé non je
dirais peut-être un capitaine d'un
bateau amiral donc un marin c'est un
marin c'est tout ce qu'on peut dire tout
ça c'est c'est du passé
lucien lacaz est né en France d'une
famille réunionnaise en 1860 mais rentre
au pays à 6 mois à peine c'est un élève
si indiscipliné que son père le renvoie
à 14 ans terminer ses études en
France après l'école navale il gravit
les échelons commandant attaché naval
dans les ambassades et
ministère de 1915 à 1917 alors que la
Première Guerre mondiale fait rage
Lucien Lacaze est ministre de la guerre
dans le gouvernement de Vivien il
s'attache à réorganiser la Marine
nationale en 18 mois il construit 500
patrouilleurs et développe l'aviation
navale mais en pleine guerre il
démissionne pour diversence de vue la
même année il a retrouvé un poste de
combat à la préfecture marine de Toulon
et est nommé
viceamiral jusqu'à sa retraite en 1922
il reste vice-président du Conseil
supérieur de la marine qu'il représente
à la Société des
Nations la conduite exemplaire de la
case lui vaudra mins
honneur membre de l'Académie de marine
de l'Académie des Beaux Arts et même en
1937 de l'Académie française où il
succède à Jul
Cambon célibataire sans enfants il
s'éteint en mars 1955 à l'âge de 95 ans
sa dépouille est portée aux
Invalides
[Musique]